what about this notion of well we are
not doing enough in the never forget
realm when it comes to nuclear
Annihilation or just Devastation not I
don't think the world the world will go
on just fine I mean there'll be a planet
here but whole life and sorry when you
say that
there will be a sphere here
there will be like cockroaches and uh
targets see I know where you're going
because
um but tell me what what could we do to
and then obviously my follow-up question
is gonna be was there an analog for
covet I've changed my mind about this uh
uh I called it about as cleanly as
somebody can call it and then it
happened and then we denied that it was
coming out of the Wuhan Institute of
virology
and we're also denying that we are
trying to Corner
a conventional
enemy who also possesses unconventional
weapons which
pardon my French but this is just the
dumbest thing I can imagine all the same
people who said that Putin would never
invade Ukraine uh are right here telling
us exactly why this is safe which it
isn't
we are This is the End we're on borrowed
time
and we're not going to avoid this we
don't have the right leaders
you know this just doesn't make any
sense and the reason it doesn't make any
sense
is because people need to be so
proximate to the problem that it plays
on their mind and they can't think about
anything else and
um so let's assume for the moment that
uh this is some sort of biological
weapons convention work around
that may have spilled over through a wet
Market or something like that
and then we're in Ukraine and we're not
allowed uh to question why we are
going to higher and higher levels of
escalation now I don't know about you
but almost all of my ancestors came from
Ukraine and
if you ask Jews Ashkenazi Jews about
where they came from in that region they
used to they usually say something like
well it's a little region that sometimes
is Poland and sometimes it was
Lithuanian sometimes it was Ukraine and
sometimes it was Russian so it was a
Belarus
we cannot afford to have these borders
oscillate as they have always oscillated
in fact they didn't oscillate if you
look at a time lapse much after World
War II up until the fall of the Berlin
wall because of the Specter of nuclear
Annihilation and I will point out that
teller famously came from the I think
the Lutheran gymnasium in Budapest with
the Laszlo rats as his high school math
teacher it's alarmed and uh and with
zillars and Von Neumann and like the
world's greatest Secondary High School
the world's greatest High School JV team
give it up for the Lutheran juveniles
and then
um
came from a town which I'm now forced to
call leviv
which I think I I always grew up saying
something closer to levov and
that is a Polish town in eastern like
Northeastern Ukraine where we're
fighting ukrainians are fighting like
eight seconds by Hypersonic missile to
the Border in Poland
so I'm not supposed to say I called it
but we're insane I mean just this twin
nuclei problem within the space of the
time that I was talking about it
we're facing potential
absolute cataclysms
and you know we're now funding more Eco
Health Alliance we're we're trying to
figure out if we should be sending
planes after sending tanks
into Ukraine we're not supposed to
discuss it nobody knows what's going on
um
I don't know what we're doing but I do
know that we're playing Russian roulette
and we're not going to be surviving this
if we keep playing this every time
somebody wants to change a border in
Central and Eastern Europe and just you
know lingering on that one one moment
longer thinking about in our community
in the Jewish Community every single
Jewish community in San Diego Los
Angeles Washington DC there is some
tribute to the Holocaust or you know
there's some Memorial to the Holocaust
uh bigger one smaller ones you know
Washington DC and LA are two notable
ones and then of course in Israel vashem
um
I I was thinking of you know kind of
getting your take on it we don't have we
have one Hiroshima and there's one
Nagasaki and there's those are the two
plan there's there's places I mean here
in San Diego we actually have a Peace
Garden and then in Japanese but there's
nothing as visceral as uh if you've been
to any of these Holocaust Memorial I've
only been to Yad vashem actually I
should come to see him is powerful but
it's not I wouldn't put it in my top
five yeah so I so that's a Lacuna in my
uh Jewish Journey but but at any rate
why aren't why don't we kind of
stigmatize not about the morality I
think it was ultimately moral and it was
a good decision by Truman but but
ultimately
if we had more awareness you've called
for with with deadly seriousness the
resumption of tests nobody listens the
resumptions of above ground rare rare
and controlled and and moderate but to
to bring to a visceral sense the notion
of what we're playing with literal
atomic fire the two monuments that I
would recommend above all others to uh
those lost in the Holocaust
or maybe three
okay so the Berlin
Memorial I can't even explain it
you know it's basically these Stones
these pillars and they start off very
shallow you could have a picnic on one
and you wander into this thing
and the height just gets higher and
higher and higher and it's mind numbing
and you lose all perspective as to where
you are and you start to realize what
happens when life is devalued and
degraded
and all you see is the coldest deer
Stones it is
who thought it reminds me of Bohemian
Rhapsody it made sense to Freddie
Mercury to write this thing but if you
describe it let's write a really long
song that mimics several operas that
makes no sense uh that I would never
have greenlit this project because I'm
an idiot right the next one is Bobby Yar
uh go to Kiev and try to keep yourself
from feeling
sickness of standing near this ditch
where people were just machine gunned
and executed
it's a visceral thing that will cause
you to lose your
and I guess the last one that really
matters to me
which isn't even about Jews is uh
there's an amazing sculpture of a boxing
ring on an angle
and it's to the cinti which is sort of a
Aroma Community
boxing Legend named Johannes trollman
who
was very popular in German circles as a
great boxing Legend he sort of was using
the Muhammad Ali technique and being
highly athletic rather than just large
and Powerful
and he was very good looking
swarthy complexion and he fought in
Germany
and the Nazis took his you know there
was a decision against him
and the crowd was having none of it
because they knew boxing so
the Germans the Nazis uh were faced with
the idea that this was not going down
and so they said okay we're going to
change the rules to neutralize this
guy's Style
so he divorces his wife to save her life
I mean I'm just it's hard not to get
emotional about this
he covers himself his dark skin with
flower to mock the Aryan preoccupation
with purity
and he loses
and this guy gets sent to a camp and
they're using him to train other people
and put on exhibitions and finally they
can't take it anymore and I think that
they just forget whether he got a hoe in
the back of his head or a single bullet
but it took us until recently to
reinstate his boxing championship that
was taken away from him
I'd go to those three memorials see how
you do but yeah but my point is it won't
last
the the it'll wear off yeah the human
the treadmill if you've never had a
near-death experience for like two weeks
yeah every cup of water is it you know
when Warren Zevon was dying
I think David Letterman asked him what
you know is there any message in this
you know that you're about to die you've
had this incredible uh
Canon of songs that you've written and
performed is there any lesson and
Warren's even said enjoy every sandwich
and you know sandwich is a funny word
it says deadly serious point which is
you don't appreciate
just the sheer Joy Of Being Alive
because you can't there's no way to keep
these lessons in mind we're not going to
explode it above I mean it's the smart
thing to do but everyone's going to say
well you're going to contaminate the
atmosphere it's like and then you're
gonna get on to the next thing and
you're not going to think about it and
it reminds me of in New Orleans when
Katrina hit
and the Levee broke
and I remember somebody on TV saying who
could possibly imagine
that the levy would break and I thought
didn't Led Zeppelin sing a song called
what they do yeah I mean it's just I
don't understand it but I've come to
accept that most humans cannot live with
abstract knowledge if something hasn't
happened in 20 years it's not it's not
going to happen if it's never happened
and you never need to worry about
anything that's a low probability
doesn't need to be thought about in the
context of I think it's exactly right
[Music]
thank you